- Hi y'all man, my name
is Vandaveon Huggins.
This my boy Mike right here.
- 'Sup.
And, you know,
we're tryin' to make
like a little documentary
thing and what not.
We really are liking
Bonnaroo, like we are enjoying
it and what not.
- Woo!
- But how could it be better,
you know what I mean?
Y'all got any ideas
about how the festival
could be better, though?
- More chairs.
- More chairs and less rules.
- And less rules?
- In reality.
- More music, all the time.
- More music all the time?
- All the time.
- Hey, we got an idea.
Tell us if you like this idea.
We already floated this one.
Sometimes bands be playin'
in different places.
- Right.
- And what if they all
play the same place
at the same time?
- Yes.
- Right?
- Everyone together, woo!
- Yeah, everyone
together, give me a woo.
- [Both] Woo!
- I love it, man, amen.
And we saw that this
jar was makin' lemonade
and what not,
and I was thinkin'
sometimes what you wanna do
is put comedy up into
what you be doin'.
Would you be willin'
to, you make a lemonade
and then go like
this and be like,
and then say,
"Oh, is that lemonade
or is that pee juice?"
See, and then it's like
a mystery for them,
you know what I'm talkin' about?
- He bein' stupid right now.
- Would that make it better?
You think that would make,
would that be better?
- Not really.
- Naw, you don't think so?
- No.
- You know what I think?
Y'all got corn dogs, right?
- Yeah.
- Giant corn dogs.
- They giant corn dogs, man.
- They should be
sellin' giant porn dogs.
- See y'all, he said
y'all should be sellin'
giant porn dogs.
See, see that's funny, isn't it?
And in the comedy you can put
the comedy inside the food,
you know what I'm talkin' about?
- Burning Man.
- What's that?
- Big burning man.
- Yeah, like have a
burning man back there.
Like a wicker man and
set him on fire, right.
Or like a big pretzel,
right, something like that.
- What about you burn his dick?
- You ask 'er.
- And then burn its dick.
Like set his little
wicker dick on fire.
Like it'd be like
this, a wicker man,
and have a dick, like this,
and then just be like--
- He bein' stupid.
- "Lemonade, lemonade"
and fire dick.
- [Mike] He bein' stupid.
- You know what I mean?
- See, y'all laughin'.
See, that would make it funny.
- You bein' stupid right now.
- Be like, wicker man, oh,
and then make his
hands go like this,
oh, my dick on fire.
My dick on fire.
- Shut up, man.
- Everybody be linin'
up for some of that
lemonade then, man.
- He bein' stupid right now.
- They be all linin'
up for lemonade.
Oh yeah, you know
what y'all should do,
what I think would
be good, though?
- What?
- Insert some comedy into it--
- Yes!
- 'Cause if y'all said,
"Your dick gotta be this high
"to be on a ride."
- Ha, that'd be great.
(laughs)
- I can't get on.
- Get a ruler out.
- Yeah, every
single person, man.
- You'd confuse so many people.
- Twelve inches only.
- Your titties got to be out
- to here, you know
what I'm talkin' about?
- Oh yeah, oh yeah.
- You know what
I'm talkin' about.
- Only if I get to
squeeze 'em all.
- You're giving me
some good ideas here.
- You get to what?
- I get to be the
judge on the titties.
- Oh, okay, hey,
I'm cool with that.
Can I be here to
see that, though?
Can I witness that situation?
- Oh yeah.
- Can I get a witness?
- Yeah, I'll be your witness.
Thank you man, thank you all.
Thanks man, I appreciate it.
- Show us your tits.
- You got it, oh,
show us your tits.
- [Mike] That be
funny right here.
- Show us your tits,
see that's funny
right there, man.
- Woo.
Thank you.
- Thanks Chelsea.
Alright Sarah.
Is that right?
- That's right.
- Like Sarah Connor's
in the Terminator.
I mean seriously,
y'all should put that
Burning Man with the
burning dick on back there.
- We'll think about it.
- Give it, just give
it some thought.
- Alright.